thanks to Nvidia studio and Razer for
sponsoring this video one week ago a
man's dream became
big Stadium a state-of-the-art visual
effects Arena the motivation for
creating a corridor stadium was to
encounter new original renders which
could be called through digital art to
realize this dream he secretly chose the
best VFX artists from the corridor Crew
He called them the iron VFX artists the
Invincible men of digital skills iron
artist Unreal Engine Sam gorsky iron
artist After Effects Nico perringer iron
artist engineer Ren weichmann and iron
artist glender Peter France
Corridor stadium is the arena where the
iron artists await the challenges of
Master digital creators from around the
internet both the iron artist and
Challenger have just two hours to tackle
the secret special asset of the day
using all their skills senses and
creativity they're going to prepare a
series of renders never seen before
they'll do it all on our Razer Blade 15
and 17 workstations powered by Nvidia
gpus and if ever a challenger wins
against the iron artist they will gain
the people's Ovation and fame forever
what inspiration does today's Challenger
bring and how will the iron artist fight
back the heatsink will be on
and today's contest
is Jordan Allen
Jordan today it is your responsibility
to choose one of the iron artists here
wisely
I am a glutton for punishment Peter
I Choose You
looks like someone wants to step into
the blender
not unless I escape
like Houdini Jordan you have challenged
Peter and didn't win you gained the
respect
of your peers
comes a grand prize of 100 US dollars
this is iron artist America contestants
take your seats for this challenge we
have provided a secret ingredient some
say it is the oldest 3D model of all
time and that secret ingredient is
oh my gosh the pyramid one of the
default shapes Child's Play honestly of
all the default shapes that it could
have been this is the worst news for me
I never expected it would be a pyramid
scheme
I already have the render made in my
head all I have to do is put it on the
computer
I do not
this secret ingredient has a total of
five polygons and five vertices the mesh
must stay intact you can scale it up but
don't ever even think about adjusting it
um Hill you will be given two hours to
complete all three dishes here but first
you will be allowed access to the asset
Pantry where you can grab any sort of
files you need to make what you want you
have two minutes to transfer everything
you can but you can only transfer it to
these USB 2.0 thumb drives I think I'll
grab one or two things it's time to kick
some asset give me the thumb drive
oh
are you okay sorry
artists to The Pantry
I know what I gotta do hard part is
doing it
two minutes starting now
slow dude that's so slow I have a
pre-prepared folder you have now wasted
your first 30 seconds whoa okay
oh no this is not good
come around there's a lot of files that
are still transferring and whatever
transfers is what you get this is insane
I'll just I'm just gonna go with
whatever's fastest
oh no one minute on the clock oh you're
starting from scratch you just canceled
everything
baguettes I would like the bag
I'm there
uh
uh whatever this is and slab it yeah I
don't know um striped bass
go go go go go go go
please I need this right now in 10
seconds I am pulling that card from the
computer the five seconds four three
[Applause]
this did not go very well oh oh
15 seconds
straight to your eyes sure clinch
surface imperfections
I am pulling this thumb drive give me
more time
I don't know if I got what I need
I really hope I didn't actually like
imagine if it corrupted everything yes
everything's corrupted
I'm sorry that you were not able to get
all of the assets you wanted okay I've
got some geometry to work with yeah and
I've got some materials to work it's not
a lot but I think it's enough I got a
baguette and a sea bass let's do this
the first task will be to create the
appetizer that is a render that is only
the secret ingredient and nothing else
which will lead into the main course
where you get to do whatever you want
you could like throw whatever you want
as long as it's still featuring the main
pyramid and any good meal requires a
good dessert you're gonna make a meme
I mean you said you have two hours and
that time begins now
I think I'm going to break up my time
into chunks so I'm going to do 30 minute
appetizer our main course and then 30
minute dessert I'm working on the
appetizer first I'm gonna get this out
of the way I'm gonna make something that
I believe is passable look I'm trying to
think outside the box I know they got
one of their own in the competition but
I'm trying to bring something a little
different to the team I can see that
Peter is making great strides but I can
tell by something that Jordan's doing is
he's got a more complex vision in mind I
think the biggest hurdle is finding
complexity and simplicity see the beauty
of today's ingredients is that it forces
the competitors to return to the roots
when you look at the history of CG
renders you know there were three shapes
that were designed in the very beginning
you have the sphere you have the cube
and you had the pyramid these three
shapes floated over chrome waters for
years inspiring many many artists and
today we get to return to that art form
our contestants are deep in thought and
busy working on works of Arts so in the
meantime
a word from our sponsor right now our
artists are deep in focused utilizing
the full Hardware cost of their brains
while pushing the limits of these
state-of-the-art razor blade mobile
workstations powered by nvidia's GeForce
RTX 3080 TI gpus they're able to bake
dishes seven times faster than any Fruit
Stand these machines feature 16 of the
fastest vram gigs ever shipped in a
laptop combined with rapid-force scaling
to optimize GPU demands in real time the
only time that matters unlike downtime
thanks to the extensively tested Studio
drivers this multi-billion dollar Studio
can rely on tools just working this
ensures that our artists need only worry
about their Creative Vision while they
maximize the clock speed of their
eyeballs against the 144hz refresh rate
of their 4K screens and with every
second counting down to the completion
of their Michelin star renders now is
the time for them to prove whether or
not they are Damascus steel or cast iron
and if you want to test your metal click
that link in the description to find out
more about these laptops and nvidia's
studio now back to
it we are here with the contestants it
has been one hour since the competition
has begun one hour left
I see where you're going with this
Jordan uh you know I'm really enjoying
seeing these polygons flying across
their screens if they're up to me I
would take a completely different route
I know I think I saw Jordan check his
wrists as if to look at the time is that
a good sign or bet it's a bad time he
has no watch
and we hear nothing but clicks and
Clacks in the studio here as it's quiet
as our artists here focus on what they
do best I can't get caught up in the
minutiae I gotta move on I'm so close to
Calling it Quits on my app and I'm very
happy with it um oh my God
oh shoot I don't know I mean Peter's a
very talented artist we all know this so
he could be working on anything right
now I'm gonna get started on my speakers
I have to let this go I'm getting hungry
yes chef oh did you just hit render I
hit render it's not rendering there we
go it's rendering excuse my language but
fudge fingers dude I just had a crash I
want you to look at this
oh please
we're good we're good baby thank you
Houdini um okay main course oh my God no
half of my assets are corrupted from one
red yanked out the flash drive you have
so much fish dude
let there be fish
[Laughter]
okay you know what I'm just gonna load
in everything I have I have just like a
few random animals some like antique
furniture items and a baguette so I
gotta think of a scene that includes the
three of those
artists and you have made some wonderful
progress you have even completed some
appetizers I want to hear what the other
iron artists have to say about what you
guys have been cooking up there's a lot
of layers to this as an artist I don't
want to tell you how to interpret the
art
God is such a freaking little judges boy
what was that where's the inspiration
for this coming from so this is the
future 12 seconds later and how far
we've come in the process and I hope
that this makes you feel warm and tingly
inside and you know makes you feel like
give me a hundred dollars so all right
hi
I'm gonna be honest I forgot about the
pyramid oh
you must include the pyramid in the main
course of course of course I was going
to do that you could include the pyramid
probably like somewhere in the
background okay but seriously what does
the pyramid mean to you
um well the pyramid reminds me of a
pyramid scheme similar to
um feudalistic capitalism of society
that we live in right now where uh the
the bottom part of the pyramid um is
just serving the the very top part of
the pyramid which is reflected in my
artwork here as you can see yeah oh okay
I get it
yeah everyone's just slaving away for
like 100 bucks right yep you have less
than 30
. uh I'm having some render issues right
now I'm just trying to get it like get
some sort of visual on where my render's
at I can see it in the viewport just
fine it looks good but we're in crunch
time now and I'm having some issues so
wish me luck like literally all of the
assets that I have will be in this
render but I don't know how to get a
pyramid into this like I have a
metaphorical pyramid going on as far as
the real pyramid wait I have an idea as
you can tell I'm in panic mode I don't
know what I'm doing anymore I'm losing
function wait I haven't even started the
meme uh you know dessert and dinner is
as important as The Landing in
gymnastics if their meal is great but
your dessert sucked well it might as
well the whole meal might have sucked I
mean just ask you know everybody who
liked Game of Thrones is that what they
think of the series
kind of the same thing the worst thing
that can happen to you as a chef is if
one of your patrons leaves your
restaurant wanting more going to another
restaurant and continuing to eat dinner
and then continuing to eat dinner that
is the worst that's the biggest shame
that Chef can taste it's like why don't
we resume dinner elsewhere
[Laughter]
[Music]
dish to be including texts if it's going
to be a joke with text
If Your Meme requires photoshopping you
will have to have it photoshopped until
the time is up
you might just hit the snip tool the
good Lord be awful I don't even know
three and a half minutes
I see these worried looks coming from
the table I know I smell burnt assets
and then I started tweaking it
you know what they might only have two
minutes left but with these fast laptops
you can do a lot in two minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can do a lot in one minute
and it's amazing how they've had this
much time to render that app once this
alarm goes off I am removing the laptops
from your Possession looks like one
Chef's ready to go I'm done
hi I'm Diggity done eight
seven
six let's hope at least something has
landed on Jordan's play tonight
why don't you taking it
[Music]
why did I keep tweaking I don't know
spoken with such confidence I'm mentally
hungry and I just need some good renders
to satisfy these eyeballs
artists who have finished your renders
and it is now time to present them to
the judges may I just say it is an honor
to be presenting my work in front of you
talented and handsome men today
permission to speak freely but let them
speak Guapo comes to mind gorgeous
handsome intelligent fantastic may I
just says
the judging begin I present to you my
appetizer hmm is that the color logo do
you see any pyramids wait a minute are
they all pyramids I I sense tiny
pyramids everywhere the color is great
there's this naturalistic effect that
the bokeh it feels like it's coming
through a physical lens yeah usually
Jordan you're so dark and dreary and
just it's so interesting to see you open
up this this new page it's beautiful
it's beautiful
uh what is that inside it sorry
something's just sharp hit my eye
there's something wrong with this dish
oh
oh whoopsie
[Laughter]
I didn't even look oh I feel sick
frankly after trying this were you
trying to make the corridor yes I was
you could have just looked up at the
door for the sizing and honestly all of
it I've had my fill thank you hey guys
this appetizer is called First Mid
[Music]
oh this is very
filling appetizer actually you order
nachos and they're like anything else
like no that is my dinner wow what a
what a glowing response I find it
fascinating that you have managed to
model an entire scene of a guy sitting
by a Fireside in a forest amongst the
mountains using nothing but a primitive
pyramid including the ground plane that
you flipped upside down I like the image
tells a story but much like with Jordan
I perhaps question if you are perhaps
running from the pyramid rather than
embracing it that is what I find to be
tasty about this
about this I like that sauce not what I
expected but still quite interesting
this is one of Peter's trademark dishes
I would expect nothing less for you
thank you Chef all right main course I
present to you my main course
[Music]
where are my eyes solid question so this
is actually pretty cool I'm really
digging the composition like you got a
lot of symmetry going on and that's the
whole point of the pyramid I like the
use of characters the recolored Foxtown
robots the robots The Columns the
background the environment so great one
might argue that you have a Shader
mistake happening on the pyramid but I
would argue that those streaks and lines
make the image more interesting and
perhaps add an element of
non-photorealism to an otherwise
geometric and photo real image that said
the hollow eyes are a little creepy as
his friends weird like double lip I will
not step on that review at all thank you
Chef Peter what is your main course dish
for us tonight this dish is named
Society okay
[Applause]
thank you
okay oh this one sit for a second it
says pyramid on the menu right yeah it's
a pyramid on the menu yeah it did say
pyramid on the menu I'm sorry but this
note in there sorry uh is this I'm just
making sure this is the right dish well
you know there is some pyramids uh as
gemstones on the bread yeah it's like
you order a hamburger and then they come
and give you a big pile of french fries
with like little
lovely composition thank you Chef it is
clear why you are an iron chef but today
it seemed that as an Iron Chef you want
to make your own meal my stomach isn't
full I need dessert bring the dessert
card over please for dessert I have
prepared something that I'm sure we can
all relate to
enjoy
what a delight for me what a delightful
meme oh my gosh this this dessert has me
floating on cloud nine I'm tickled dude
this has little sprinkles that pop in
your mouth like I'm like giggling just
trying to Feast on this
thank you that's clever more clever than
I thought you know a last minute rush
panicked meme would be thank you Chef it
was rushed and panicked thank you so
much all right um I hope this render
makes up for the last one and more so
that's all I'm gonna say
ah
there's the pyramid in my dish
dude what the freak is going on
I did not know it was possible to be
this disappointed damn girl I'm gonna be
honest I forgot about the pyramid in
this game
all I did was look for a triangle and
when I just saw this like weird
glitching fish that's not even like
fully framed up I I have a strong
aversion to Authority what can I say
that's why we that's why we have them
here yeah he's constantly challenging us
constantly challenging us it's amazing
how funny something with such little
effort can be artists congratulations on
finishing this challenge Sam who won
this challenge in your mind while
Jordan's effort was very Noble
ultimately Peter's dishes were the most
flavorful and tasty and I say this with
great reservation as his rebellious
attitude soured my expectations thank
you Chef thank you Peter while your
renters were delightful and expertly
crafted and I would expect nothing less
the end of the day Jordan featured the
ingredient that we requested the most
therefore he is my iron artist of this
challenge it seems to me that we have a
tie and that means I am the tie-breaking
vote now today's winner
of VFX iron artist
is
[Music]
Jordan are you
[Applause]
[Music]
sure
[Music]
Jordan today you have proven worthy of
being an iron artist congratulations
thank you chefs
welcome thank you chefs it's an honor
Peter is just the cream of the crop and
it took every ounce of energy and belief
in myself that I had in me I am rung dry
I'm gonna go take a 72-hour nap and come
back a new Iron artist this is this is
surreal wow what are you gonna spend
this on honestly
I did not expect to get it I will have
to game plan I have nothing prepared for
this money this was a lot of fun we want
to do this again and so therefore we
need some suggestions perhaps what the
secret ingredient for the next episode
should be leave a comment down below
that'll give us some ideas in the
meantime subscribe because we got more
of these coming and I don't know who we
should have on next someone else to
challenge us
find out
now this wouldn't be a video sponsored
by Razer and Nvidia studio if we didn't
have a giveaway happening we're doing a
sweepstakes you can win a laptop for
yourself or a couple other cool prizes
the details are on our Instagram
basically you get to be an Iron Chef
also check it out there you have to
follow our Instagram anyways enter the
sweepstakes so at tour or digital go
check it out get yourself a laptop